17 was it GM night five Fisher let's go
all right what arrangement will we have
here hmm
the bishops don't have to move in order
to develop where would I like to castle
I need to get both knights and yeah okay
actually if I just move both the Knights
I could Castle kingside I don't want to
move my knight to here because then my
bishop isn't going to be coming out
anytime soon and I think I actually like
this as a first move not just one square
two squares
oh wait a second
okay what's unprotected now this is
protected by my knight
anything else unprotected this is
unprotected so that means this is and
nothing at nothing else so I wonder if I
could pinpoint this pawn in two moves I
think that could maybe be awkward but
there is always a knight move here that
could be defending so that wouldn't
really turn out to be an inconvenience
so that said I think I'm gonna start
here two ideas allow my bishop to see
stop this movie for establishing two
pawns in the center and also stopping C
for establishing two pawns side by side
like that
so yeah what next what next I don't know
what I want to do with this guy I don't
like here because of what I was saying
about this bishop I don't like here
because it's obstructing this pond so
he's a problem piece for me this night
not so much play there to its natural
square and I may be wanting to do
something like d6 97 have my other night
here
whoa that's a mistake there's no way
that could be good there's absolutely no
way that that could be good
I want my pieces right here c4 I could
play here right now but I get kicked
around maybe eventually with some pond
pushes or a knight move or something
like that but actually in two moves I
forget about coming here I like this
move better here here getting to the
weak point if you could identify a weak
point in your opponent's position that
could be translating into a good plan
for you so if this Knight is here this
pond I don't have to worry about it
coming to the center
let's let my bishop see
if pond push I'll challenge it I'll take
first and then challenge that pond so my
real could see you might want to get my
queen up okay this queen is now ready to
come out but my bishop could come out
here it's the Queen but I don't like
that there's an eventual f3 move I think
I like this though I am obstructing both
of my pawns here but no no no okay I
have a plan
getting my knight eventually to this
square or maybe even this one they've
pawn push yeah that would actually be
very good
I think g3 Knight h3 and something like
Bishop takes okay whoa this is main it's
a smothered mate they did offer a take
back just as I was moving there oh that
hurts
yeah I saw their typing yeah you want to
take it back I hear you I guess I was
too quick to pull the trigger on the
half one I was too quick to pull the
trigger on that smothered mate there
yeah oh well I am okay well
well well let some still take something
away from it I can't recommend the B
form of weakening for you to say to me
here's a here's a hole in my position
and we're just two moves into the game
something right there is that's it's a
red flag right there can't you can't do
that if anything how about b3 b3 your
bishop could see and then maybe c4 is uh
on the cards that's my quick suggestion
you cannot you really cannot compromise
your position that quick no way no way
we was like Knight f3 maybe Knight to d2
trying to stay out of the way of these
pawns maybe and maybe actually in this
position Knight to d2 is an idea just
getting ready to play e4 establishing
another pawn in the center I'd probably
be having to meet it with Knight f6 and
then maybe you could be saying you know
what I insist I insist I want to get a
pawn to e4
so f3 and then e 4 that could be an
early plan for you it could be an early
plan trying to get two pawns in the
center you have one try and get a second
it becomes all the more valuable